[Music]
i'm erielle khan with the future of life
Institute and I'm excited to have FL
eyes Lucas Perry and Mei Akita tegmark
with me today to talk about AI ethics
and more specifically the value
alignment problem but first if you've
been enjoying our podcasts please take a
moment to subscribe and like this
podcast you can find us on iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play and all of the
other major podcast platforms and now ai
ethics and the value alignment problem
so first consider the statement I
believe that harming animals is bad now
that statement can mean something very
different to a vegetarian than it does
to an omnivore both people can honestly
say that they don't want to harm animals
but how they define harm is likely very
different and these types of differences
in values are common between countries
and cultures and even just between
individuals within the same town and
then we want to throw AI into the mix
how can we train a eyes to respond
ethically to situations when the people
involved still can't come to an
agreement about what an ethical response
should be but the problem is even more
complicated because often we don't even
know what we really want for ourselves
let alone how to ask an AI to help us
get what we want and as we've learned
with stories like that of King Midas we
need to be really careful what we ask
for that is when King Midas asked the
genie to turn everything to gold
he didn't really want everything like
his daughter and his food turned to gold
and we would prefer that an AI we
designed recognized that there's often
implied meaning in what we say even if
we don't say something explicitly for
example if we jump into an autonomous
car and ask it to drive us to the
airport as fast as possible implicit in
that request is the assumption that
while we might be okay with some
moderate speeding we intend for the car
to still follow most rules of the road
and not drive so fast as to put anyone's
life in danger or take illegal routes
that is when we say as fast as possible
we mean within the rules of law not
within the laws of physics
and these examples are just the tiniest
tip of the iceberg given that I didn't
even mention artificial general
intelligence and how that can be
developed such that its goals aligned
with our values so as I mentioned a few
minutes ago I'm really excited to have
Lucas and Mayer joining me today
maiya is a co-founder of the future of
life Institute she is interested in how
social sciences can contribute to
keeping AI beneficial and her background
is in social psychology
Lucas works on AI and nuclear weapons
risk related projects at FLI his
background is in philosophy with a focus
on ethics man Lucas thanks for joining
us today it's a pleasure thank you
thanks for having us so before we get
into anything else one of the big topics
that comes up a lot when we talk about
AI and ethics is this concept of value
alignment and so I was hoping you could
both maybe talk just a minute about what
value alignment is and why it's
important to this question of AI and
ethics so a value alignment in my view
is bringing ai's goals actions
intentions and decision-making processes
in accordance with what humans deemed to
be the good or what we see is valuable
or what our ethics actually are so for
me from the point of view of psychology
of course I have to put the humans at
the center of my inquiry so from that
point of view value alignment you know
you can think about it also in terms of
humans relationships with other humans
but I think it's even more interesting
when you add artificial agents into the
mix because now you have an entity that
you know is so wildly different from
from humans yet we would like it to
embrace our goals and and our values in
order to keep it beneficial for us so I
think the question of value alignment is
very very central to to keeping AI
beneficial so just to expand on what I
said earlier the project of value
alignment is in the end creating
beneficial AI it's working on what it
means for something to be beneficial
what beneficial AI exactly entails and
then learning how to technically
instantiate that into machines and AI
systems and also
building the proper like social and
political context for that sort of
technical work to be done and for it to
be fulfilled and manifested in our
machines and NAIS
and so when when you're thinking of AI
and ethics is value alignment basically
synonymous just another way of saying AI
and ethics or is it a subset within this
big topic of AI in ethics
well I think that they have different
connotations if one's thinking about AI
ethics I think that one is tending to be
more so focused on on applied ethics and
normative ethics one might be thinking
about the application of AI systems and
algorithms and machine learning in
domains in the present day and in the
near future so one might think about
autumn ization and other sorts of things
I think that when one is thinking about
value alignment it's much more broader
and expands also into into meta ethics
and really sort of couches and frames
the problem of AI ethics as something
which happens over decades and which has
a tremendous impact I think that value
alignment has a much broader connotation
than what AI epics has traditionally had
I think it all depends on you know how
you define value alignment I think if
you take the very broad definition that
that Lukas has just proposed I think
that yes it's it's probably includes AI
epochs but you can also think a bit more
narrowly simply instantiating your own
values and in into AI systems and having
them adopt your goals in that case I
think there are other issues as well
because if you think about it from the
point of view of psychology for example
then it's not just about which values
get instantiated and how you do that how
you solve the technical problem but also
we know that that humans even if they
know what what goals they have and what
values they uphold it's very very hard
for them sometimes to actually act in
accordance to them because they have all
sorts of cognitive and emotional
affective limitations so in that case I
think you know value alignment is in
this narrow sense it's basically not
sufficient we also need to think about
AIS and applications of my eyes in terms
of how do they help us and how do they
make sure that we gain the cognitive
competencies that we need to be moral
beings and to be really what we should
be not just what we are right and I
guess just to expand on what I was just
saying I mean valuable I'm and I think
in a more traditional sense it sort of
it goes beyond or it's more expansive
and inclusive in the it's recognizing
like a different sort of problem than
like AI ethics alone has I think that
when one is thinking about value
alignment there are elements of thinking
about some what about machine ethics but
also about social political technical
and ethical issues surrounding the end
goal of eventually creating AGI whereas
AI epics can be more narrowly
interpreted just as as certain sorts of
like specific cases where AI is having
impact and implications in our lives in
like the next ten years
whereas value alignments really thinking
about the instantiation of ethics and
machines
and making machine systems that are
corrigible and robust and docile which
will create a world that we're all happy
about living in
okay so I think that actually is going
to flow really nicely into my next
question and that is at FLI we tend to
focus on existential risks and I was
hoping you could talk a little bit about
how issues of value alignment are
connected to the existential risks that
we concern ourselves with
right so we can think of AI systems as
being very powerful optimizers we can
imagine there being like a list of all
possible futures and what intelligence
is good for is for modeling the world
and then committing to and doing actions
which constrain the set of all possible
worlds to ones which are desirable
so intelligence is sort of the means by
which we get to an end and ethics is the
end towards which we strive so these are
how these two things really integral and
work together and how AI without ethics
makes no sense and how ethics without AI
or intelligence in general it also just
doesn't work so in terms of existential
risk there are possible futures that
intelligence can lead us to where earth
originating intelligent life no longer
exists either intentionally or by
accident and so value alignment sort of
fits in by constraining the set of all
possible futures by working on like
technical work by doing political and
social work and also work in ethics to
constrain the actions of AI systems such
the existential risks do not occur such
that by some sort of technical oversight
by some misalignment of values by some
misunderstanding of what we want the AI
generates an existential risk
so we should remember that Homo sapiens
represents an existential risk to itself
also we are creating nuclear weapons we
have more of them that we need so many
in fact that we could destroy the entire
planet with them and not to mention Homo
sapiens is also represented an
existential risk for all other species
the problem with AI is that we're
introducing in the makes a whole new
agent that is by definition supposed to
be more intelligent more powerful than
us and also autonomous so as Lucas
mentioned it's very important to think
through what kind of things and
abilities do we delegate to these AIS
and how can we make sure that they have
the survival and the flourishing of our
species in mind so I think this is where
value alignment comes in as a safeguard
against these very terrible and global
risks that we can imagine coming from AI
right and what makes doing that so
difficult is beyond beyond the technical
issue of just having a AI researchers
and a safety researchers knowing how to
just get AI systems to actually do what
we want without creating a universe of
paperclips there's also this terrible
social and political context in which
this is all happening where there is
really great game theoretic incentives
to be the first person to create
artificial general intelligence so in a
race to create AI a lot of these these
efforts that seem very obvious and
necessary could be cut in favor of more
raw power and I think that that's
probably one of the biggest risks for us
not succeeding in creating value line AI
okay so I right now it's predominantly
technical AI people who are considering
mostly technical AI problems how to
solve different different problems is
usually a you need a technical approach
for this but when it comes to things
like value alignment and ethics most of
the time I'm hearing people suggest that
we can't leave that up to just the
technical AI researchers and so I was
hoping you could talk a little bit about
who should be part of this discussion
why we need more people involved how we
can get more people involved stuff like
that
sure so maybe if I didn't just break the
problem down into what I view to be the
three different parts then talking about
it will make a little bit more sense so
we can break down the value alignment
problem into three separate parts the
first one is going to be the technical
issues the issues surrounding actually
creating artificial intelligence the
issues of ethics so the end towards
which we strive the the set of possible
futures which we would be happy in
living and then also there's there's the
governance and the coordination in the
international problem so we can sort of
view this as a problem of intelligence a
problem of agreeing on the end towards
which intelligence is driven towards and
also the political and social context in
which all of this happens and so so thus
far there's certainly been a a focus on
the technical issue so so there's been a
big rise in in the field of AI safety
and in attempts to generate beneficial
AI attempts at creating safe AGI and
mechanisms for avoiding reward hacking
and other sorts of things that happen
when systems are trying to optimize the
utility function the concrete problems
on AI safety paper has been really
important and sort of illustrates some
of these technical issues but even
between technical AI safety research and
ethics there's disagreement about
something like also like machine ethics
so like how important is machine ethics
where does machine ethics fit into
technical AI safety research like how
much time and energy should we put into
certain kinds of technical AI safety
research versus how much time and effort
should we put into issues in in
governance and coordination and
addressing the AI arms race issue and
how much of ethics do we really need to
solve so I think that there's a really
important and open question regarding
how do we apply and invest our limited
resources in sort of addressing these
three important cornerstones in value
alignment so the technical issue the
issues and ethics and then issues in
governance and coordination and how do
we optimize working on these issues
given the timeline that we have how much
resources should be put into each
and I think that's an open question and
yeah one that certainly needs to be
addressed more about about how we're
gonna move forward given limited
resources I do think though that you
know the focus so far has been so much
on the technical aspect you know as you
were saying because there are there are
other aspects to this problem that need
to be tackled and what I'd like to
emphasize is that we cannot solve the
problem if we don't pay attention to the
other aspect as well so I'm gonna try to
defend for example psychology here which
has been you know largely ignored I
think in the conversation so from the
point of view of psychology I think the
value alignment problem is double-fold
in a way it's about a triad of
interactions human AI other humans right
so we are extremely social animals we
interact a lot with other humans and we
need to align our goals and values with
theirs and psychology has focused a lot
on that we have very sophisticated set
of psychological mechanisms that allow
us to engage in very rich social
interactions but even so we don't always
get it right societies have created a
lot of suffering a lot of moral harm
injustice unfairness throughout the ages
so for example we are very ill prepared
by our own instincts and emotions to
deal with intergroup relations so that's
very hard now you know people coming
from the technical side they can say oh
you know we'll just gonna have a I learn
our preferences like em first
reinforcement learning is a proposal
that says you know that basically
explains how to keep humans in the loop
so it's a it's a proposal for
programming AI such that it gets its
reward not from achieving a goal but
from getting good feedback from a human
because it achieved the goal so the hope
is that this way I can be correctable
and can learn from human preferences but
as a psychologist I am I am intrigued
but I understand that this is actually
very hard are we humans even capable of
conveying the right information about
our preferences do we even have access
to them ourselves or is this all
happening at some sort of subconscious
level sometimes knowing what we want is
really hard and
how do we even choose between our own
competing preferences so this involves a
lot more you know sophisticated
abilities like impulse control executive
function etc so you know I think that if
we don't pay attention to that as well
in addition to to solving the technical
problem I think we are very likely to
not get it right so I'm going to want to
come back to this question of who should
be involved and how we can get more
people involved but one of the reasons
that I'm talking to both of you today is
because you actually have made some
steps in broadening this discussion
already and that you set up a workshop
that did bring together a
multidisciplinary team to talk about
value alignment and I was hoping you
could tell us a bit more about how that
workshop went what interesting insights
were gained that might have been
expressed during the workshop what you
got out of it why you think it's
important towards the discussion etc so
just to give a few facts about the
workshop the workshop took place in
December 2017 in Long Beach California
and we were very lucky to have two
wonderful partners and Corgan izing this
workshop the Bergeron Institute and the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
and the idea for the workshop was very
much to have a very interdisciplinary
conversation about about value alignment
and reframe it is not just a technical
problem but also one that involves
disciplines such as philosophy and
psychology political science and and so
on so we were very lucky actually to
have a fantastic group of people there
representing all these disciplines and
the conversation was was very lively and
and we we discussed topics all the way
from near-term considerations and an AI
and how we aligned AI to our goals and
also all the way to thinking about AGI
and even super intelligence so it was a
fascinating range both of topics
discussed and also the perspectives
being represented
so my inspiration for the workshop was
being really interested in ethics and
and the end towards which this is all
going you know what really is the point
of creating AGI and perhaps even
eventually superintelligence what is it
that is good and what is it that is
valuable and broadening from that and
becoming more interested in value
alignment the the conversation thus far
has been primarily understood as
something that is this purely technical
so value alignment has only been seen as
something that is for technical AI
safety researchers to work on because
there there are technical issues
regarding AI safety and and how you get
a eyes to do really simple things
without destroying the world or ruining
the million other things that we care
about but this is really as we discussed
earlier an interdependent issue that
covers issues in meta ethics and
normative ethics applied ethics covers
issues in psychology it covers issue in
law policy governance coordination that
covers the AI arms race issue solving
the value alignment problem and creating
a future with beneficial AI is just it's
a civilizational project where we need
everyone working on all these different
issues on issues of value on issues of
like game theory among countries on on
the technical issues obviously and so
what I would really wanted to do was I
wanted to start this workshop in order
to broaden the discussion to reframe
value alignment as not just something
than in technical AI safety research but
something that really needs voices from
from all disciplines and all expertise
in order to have a really robust
conversation that reflects the
interdependent nature of the issue and
where different sorts of expertise on
the different parts of the issue can
really come together and and work on it
and is there anything specific that you
can tell us about what came out of the
workshop like were there any comments
that you thought were especially
insightful or ideas that you think are
important for people to be considering
I mean I think that for me one of the
takeaways from the workshop is that
there's still a mountain of work to do
and that there are a ton of open
questions and that this is a very very
difficult issue I think the one thing I
took away from the workshop was we
couldn't even agree on the minimal
conditions for which it would be okay to
safely deploy a GI
they're just issues that seem extremely
trivial in value alignment from the
technical side and from the ethical side
that seem very trivial but on which I
think there is very little understanding
or agreement right now
I think the workshop was a start and one
good thing that happened during the
workshop is I felt that the different
disciplines or rather their
representatives were able to sort of air
out their frustrations and also express
their expectations of the others so I
remember this quite iconic moment when
one roboticists simply said but I really
want you Attucks people to just tell me
what to implement in my system what do
you want my system to do so I think that
was that was actually very illustrative
of what Lukas was saying the need for
more joint work and I think you know
there was a lot of a lot of expectations
I think from both the technical people
towards the ethicists but also from the
ethicists in terms of like you know what
are you doing explain to us what are the
actual ethical issues that that you
think you are facing with the things
that you are building because I think
there's a lot of catching up to do on
both sides and there's much work to be
done in terms of making these
connections and bridging the gaps
and so you referred to this is sort of a
first step or an initial step what would
you like to see happen next I I don't
have any really concrete or specific
ideas for what exactly should happen
next I think that's a really difficult
question certainly like things that most
people would want or expect like I think
that in the general literature and
conversations that we were having I
think the value alignment as a word and
as something that we understand needs to
be expanded outside of the technical
context I don't think that is expanded
that far I think the more ethicists and
more moral psychologists and and people
in law policy and governance need to
come in and need to work on this issue
I'd like to see more like coordinated
collaborations specifically involving
like interdisciplinary crowds like
informing each other and addressing
issues and identifying issues and really
some sorts of like formal mechanisms for
interdisciplinary coordination on value
alignment it would be really great if
people in technical research and
technical AAS a few research and an
ethics and governance could also like
identify all of the issues in their own
fields which the resolution to those
issues and the solution to those issues
requires answers from other fields so
for example inverse reinforcement
learning is something that male was
talking about earlier and I think that's
something that we can clearly decide and
see as being interdependent on a ton of
issues in law and also in ethics and
ended value theory and so that would be
sort of like an issue or like node in
the landscape of all issues and
technical AI safety research that that
would be something that is
interdisciplinary so I think it would be
super awesome if everyone from their own
respective fields are really able to
identify the the core issues which are
interdisciplinary and able to dissect
them into the constituent components and
and sort of divide them among the
disciplines and work together on them
and identify like the different
timelines at which different issues need
to be worked on and yeah it's just
coordinating on those things
and then solo because you talked a
little bit about nodes and a landscape
but I don't think we've explicitly
pointed out that you did create a
landscape of value alignment research so
far can you talk a little bit about what
that is and how people can use it
yeah for sure so with the help of other
colleagues at the future of life
Institute like jessica cousins and
richard mala we've gone ahead and
created a value alignment conceptual
landscape and so what this is is it's
like a really big tree almost like an
evolutionary tree that you would see but
what it is is a conceptual mapping and
landscape of the value alignment problem
and what it's broken down into are the
three constituent components which we
were talking about earlier which is the
technical issues the issues and
technically creating safe AI systems
issues and ethics breaking that down
into issues and meta ethics and
normative ethics and applied ethics and
like moral psychology and descriptive
ethics where we're trying to really
understand values what it means for
something to be valuable and what is the
end towards which intelligence will be
aimed at and then also the other last
section is governance so issues in
coordination and policy and law in
creating a world where AI safety
research can proceed and where there
aren't where we don't develop or allow
like a sort of winner-take-all scenario
to rush us towards the end and not
really have a final and safe solution
towards fully autonomous powerful
systems so what the the landscape here
does is it sort of outlines all the
different conceptual nodes in each of
these areas it lays out what all the
core concepts are how they're all
related it defines the concepts and also
gives descriptions about how the
concepts fit into each of these
different sections of ethics governance
and technical AI safety research and so
the hope here is that people from
different disciplines can come and see
the truly interdisciplinary nature of
the value alignment problem to see where
ethics and governance and the technical
AI safety research stuff all fits in
together
and how this altogether really forms I
think the essential corners of the value
alignment problem and it's also nice for
researchers and other persons to
understand the concepts and the
landscape of the other parts of this
problem
I think the for example technical AI
safety researchers probably don't know
much about meta ethics so they don't
spend too much time thinking about
normative ethics and I'm sure that
ethicists don't spend very much time
thinking about technical value alignment
and how inverse reinforcement learning
is actually done and what it what it
means to do robust human imitation in
machines and what are the actual
technical ethical mechanisms that are
going to go into AI systems and so I
think that this is like a step in sort
of laying out the conceptual landscape
in introducing people to each other's
concepts it's a nice visual way of
interacting with I think a lot of
information and sort of exploring all
these different really interesting nodes
that explore a lot of like very deep
profound moral issues very difficult and
interesting technical issues and and
issues in law policy and governance that
are really important and profound and
quite interesting so you've you've
referred to this as the value alignment
problem a couple of times and I'm
curious do you see this and I'd like
both you'd answer this do you see this
as a problem that can be solved or is
this something that we just always keep
working towards and it's going to
influence you know whatever the current
general consensus is will influence how
we're designing AI and possibly AGI but
it's not ever like okay now we've solved
the value of I'm a problem so make sense
I mean I think that I think that that
sort of question really depends on your
meta ethics right so if you think the
there are moral facts if you think that
the moral statements can be true or
false and aren't just sort of
subjectively dependent upon whatever our
current values and preferences
historically and evolutionarily it
accidentally happened to be then there
is an end towards which intelligence can
be aimed that would be objectively good
and which would be the end towards which
we would strive and in that case if we
had solved the technical issue and the
governance issue and we knew that there
was a there was a concrete end towards
which we would strive that was the
actual good then the value alignment
problem would be solved but if you don't
think that there is a concrete end a
concrete good something that is that is
objectively valuable across all agents
then the value alignment problem or
value alignment in general is just sort
of a is an ongoing process in evolution
and in terms of like the technical and
governance sides of those I think the
there's nothing in the laws of physics
or I think in computer science or in
game theory that says that we can't
solve those those parts of the problem
those ones seem intrinsically like they
can be solved that's nothing to say
about how easy or how hard it is to
solve those but whether or not there is
sort of like an end towards value
alignment I think depends on on
difficult questions in meta ethics and
whether something like moral arrow
theory is true where all moral
statements are simply false and that
morality is maybe sort of just like a
human invention and which has no real
answers or whose answers are all false
yeah I think that that's sort of the
crux of whether or not value alignment
can quote be solved because I think the
technical issues and the issues and
governance are things which can be which
are in principle able to be solved
and mayor I think that regardless of
whether there is an absolute end to this
problem or not there's a lot of work
that we need to do in between and I also
think that you know in order to even
achieve this this end we need more
intelligence but as we create more
intelligent agents again you know this
problem gets magnified so there is
always going to be a race between the
intelligence that we're creating and
making sure that it is beneficial and I
think at every step of the way the more
we increase the intelligence the more we
need to think about the broader
implications and I think in the end we
we should think of artificial
intelligence also not just as as a way
to amplify our own intelligence but also
as a way to amplify our moral competence
as well you know as a way to gain more
answers regarding ethics and what our
ultimate goals should be so I think that
the interesting questions that we can do
something about are some where I sort of
an in-between we will not have the the
answer before we are creating AI so we
always have to figure out a way to know
keep up with the development of
intelligence in terms of our development
of moral competence
Soumya I want to stick with you for just
a minute when we talked for the FLI end
of your podcast one of the things she
said you're looking forward to in 2018
is broadening this conversation
and so it's hoping you could talk a
little bit more about some of what you
would like to see happen this year in
terms of getting other people involved
in the conversation who would you like
to see taking more of an interest in
this
so I think that unfortunately especially
in academia we've sort of defined our
work so much around these things that we
call disciplines and I think we're now
faced with with problems that especially
in an AI that really are a very
interdisciplinary we cannot get the
answers from just one discipline so I
would I would actually like to see in
2018 more sort of for example funding
agencies proposing and creating funding
sources for interdisciplinary projects
the way it works especially in academia
so you propose grants to do very
disciplinary defined granting agencies
another thing that that would be
wonderful
you know to start happening is you know
our education system is also very much
defined and described around these
disciplines so I feel that for example
there's a lack of courses for example
that teach students and technical fields
things about ethics moral psychology
Social Sciences and so on the converse
is also true in social sciences and in
philosophy we hear very little about
advancements in artificial intelligence
and and what's new and what are the
problems that are there so I'd like to
see more of that I'd like to see more
courses like this developed I think a
friend of mine and I we've spent some
time thinking about how many courses are
there that have an interdisciplinary
nature and actually talk about the
societal impacts of AI and there's a
handful in the entire world I think we
counted about five or six of them so so
there's a shortage of that as well but
then also educating the general public I
think thinking about the implications of
AI and also the societal implications of
AI and also the value lineman problem is
something that's probably an easier for
the general public to grasp rather than
thinking about all the the technical
aspect of how to make it more powerful
or how to make it more intelligent
so I think there's a lot to be done in
educating
funding and also just just simply having
these these conversations I also very
much admire what Lucas has been has been
doing and I hope he will expand on it
creating this conceptual landscape so
that we have people from different
disciplines understanding their terms
their concepts you know each other's
theoretical frameworks with which they
work so I think all of this is valuable
and we need to start it won't be
completely fixed in 2018 I think but I
think it's a good good time to to work
towards these these goals okay and Lucas
is there anything that you wanted to add
about what you'd like to see happen this
year I mean yeah nothing else I think to
add on to what I said earlier obviously
we just need as many people from as many
disciplines working on this issue
because it's so important but just to go
back a little bit I was also really
liking what may have said about how AI
systems and intelligence can help us
with our ethics and and and with our
governance I think that that seems like
a really good way forward potentially if
as our AI systems grow more powerful and
their intelligence they're able to
inform us more so about our own ethics
and our own preferences and our own
values about our own biases and about
what sorts of values and moral systems
are really conducive to the thriving of
human civilization and what sorts of
morality is lead to sort of navigating
the space of all possible minds in in a
way that is truly beneficial so yeah I
guess we'll be excited to see more ways
in which intelligence and AI systems can
be deployed for really tackling the
question of what beneficial AI exactly
entails you know what is beneficial mean
like we all want beneficial AI but but
what is beneficial what does that mean
what does that mean for us in a world in
which no one can agree on what
beneficial exactly entails so yeah I'm
just excited to see how this is going to
work out how it's going to involve and
and and hopefully we'll have a lot more
people joining this
work on this issue
so your comment reminded me of a quote
that I read recently that I thought was
sort of interesting I've been reading
Paula Boddingtons book toward a code of
ethics for artificial intelligence and
this was this was actually funded at
least in part if not completely by FLI
grants but she she says it's worth
pointing out that if we need AI to help
us make moral decisions better this
casts doubt on the attempts to ensure
humans always retain control over AI I'm
wondering if you have any comments on
that
yeah I don't know I think it's sort of
like this it's a specific way of like
viewing the issue or it's a specific way
of viewing what AI systems are foreign
the sort of future that we want I mean
in the end is the best of all possible
futures a world in which human beings
ultimately retain full control over AI
systems I mean if a systems are our
autonomous and and if value alignment
actually succeeds then I would hope that
we created AI systems which are more
moral than we are AI systems which have
better ethics which are which are less
biased which are more rational and which
are more benevolent and compassionate
than we are if value alignment is able
to succeed and if we're able to create
autonomous intelligent systems of that
sort of caliber of ethics and
benevolence and intelligence then I'm
not really sure what the point is of
maintaining any any sort of meaningful
human control I agree with you Lucas
that if we do manage to create in this
case I think it would have to be
artificial general intelligence that is
more moral more beneficial you know more
compassionate than we are then they
should control it's probably not so
important but in the meantime I think
while we are sort of 10 occurring with
our divisional intelligence systems I
think the issue of control is is very
important yes because we wouldn't want
to
we wouldn't be want to cut out at the
loop too early before we've managed to
properly test the system make sure that
indeed it is doing what we intended to
do right and I think the in the process
of that that it requires a
of our own moral evolution something
which we humans are really bad and slow
at you know as the president of FLI max
tegmark likes to talk about he likes to
talk about the race between our growing
wisdom and the growing power of our
technology you know human beings are
really kind of bad at keeping our wisdom
and pace with the growing power of our
technology and if we sort of look at the
the moral evolution of our species we
can sort of see huge eras in which
things which were seen as normal and
mundane and innocuous like slavery or
the subjugation of women or other sorts
of things like that today we have issues
with factory farming and animal
suffering and income inequality and just
tons of people who are living and with
exorbitant wealth that doesn't really
create much utility for them whereas
there's tons of other people who are in
poverty and who are so starving to death
there are all sorts of things that we
can see in the past as being obviously
morally wrong under the present - yeah
and so so so then we can see that
obviously there must be things like that
today and we wonder ok so you know what
are the sorts of things today that we
see is innocuous and as a normal and as
mundane that the people of tomorrow as
William McCaskill says will see us as
moral monsters how are we moral monsters
today but we what we simply can't see it
and so as we create powerful intelligent
systems and we're working on our ethics
and we're trying to really converge on
constraining the set of all possible
worlds into ones which art which are
good and and which are valuable and
ethical it really demands a moral
evolution of ourselves that we sort of
have to figure out ways to catalyze and
like work on and move through I think
faster
did I thank you um so as you consider
attempts to solve the value alignment
problem what are you most worried about
either in terms of us solving it badly
or not quickly enough or something along
those lines
and what is giving you the most hope in
terms of us being able to address this
problem
I mean so I think just like technically
speaking ignoring the likelihood of this
like the worst of all possible outcomes
would be something like an s risk so an
s risk is a subset of X risks asterisk
stands for suffering risk and so this is
a sort of risk where by some sort of
value misalignment whether it be
intentional or much more likely
accidental some seemingly astronomical
amount of suffering is produced by
deploying a misaligned AI system the way
that this was sort of function is given
certain sorts of assumptions about the
philosophy of mind about consciousness
and machines if we understand
potentially consciousness and experience
to be substrate independent meaning if
consciousness can be instantiated in in
machine systems that that you don't just
need meet to be conscious but you need
something like integrated information or
information processing or computation or
something like that then the invention
of AI systems and super intelligence and
the spreading of intelligence which
which optimizes towards any sort of
arbitrary end it could potentially lead
to vast amounts of digital suffering
which would potentially arise
accidentally or through subroutines or
simulations which would be epistemic ly
useful but that involves a great amount
of suffering and that coupled with these
artificial intelligence systems running
on on silicon and iron and not on on
squishy wet human neurons would mean
that it would be running at digital
timescales and not biological timescales
and so there would be huge amplification
of the speed at which the suffering was
run so subjectively we might infer that
a second for a computer a simulated
person on a computer would be much
greater than that for a biological
person then we can sort of reflect that
these are the sorts of risks that
ernesta risk would be something that
would be really sort of sort of bad just
any sort of way that AI can be
misaligned and lead to a great amount of
suffering and there's a bunch of
different ways that this could happen
so something like an asterisk would be
something like super terrible but it's
not really clear how likely that would
be but yeah I think that beyond that
obviously like we're worried about
existential risk we're worried about
ways that this could hurt tail or
destroy the development of Earth
originating intelligent life and you
know ways that this really might happen
or I think most likely because of this
winner-take-all scenario you that you
have with a I we've had nuclear weapons
for for a very long time now and we're
super lucky that nothing bad has
happened but I think the human
civilization is really good at getting
stuck into like minimum equilibria where
like we get locked into these into these
sort of positions where it's not easy to
escape from so it's really not easy to
disarm and get out of the nuclear
weapons situation once it's once we've
discovered it and once we start to
develop I think more powerful and robust
AI systems and I think already that a
race towards AGI and towards more and
more powerful AI might be very very hard
to stop if we don't make significant
progress on that soon if we're not able
to get a ban on leith autonomous weapons
and if we're not able to introduce any
real global coordination and that we all
just start racing towards more powerful
systems that there might be a race
towards AGI which would cut corners on
safety and potentially make the
likelihood of a existential risk or
suffering risk more likely
are you hopeful for anything I mean yeah
like if we get it right then the next
billion billion years can be super
amazing right it's just kind of hard to
internalize that and think about that
it's really hard to say I think how
likely it is that we'll succeed in any
direction but um yeah I mean I'm hopeful
that if we succeed in value alignment
that the future can be unimaginably good
and man what's scary to me is that it
might be too easy to create intelligence
but there's nothing in the laws of
physics making it hard for us and thus I
think that it might happen too fast
evolution took a long time to figure out
how to make us intelligent but that was
probably just because it was trying to
optimize for things like energy
consumption and making us a certain size
so that's scary it's scary that it's
happening so fast and I'm particularly
scared that you know it might be easy to
crack general artificial intelligence I
keep asking max max but isn't there
anything in the laws of physics that
might like you know make it tricky you
know the answer of his answer and also
that of more physicists that I've been
discussing with is that no it doesn't
seem to be the case now what makes me
hopeful is that you know we are creating
this Stuart Russell likes to give this
example you know of a message from an
alien civilization alien intelligence
that says we will be arriving in 50
years and then he poses the question
what would you do when you prepare for
that but I think with artificial
intelligence it's different it's not
like it's arriving and it's a given and
it has a certain form or shape you know
that we cannot do anything about we are
actually creating artificial
intelligence and I think that's that's
what makes me hopeful that if we
actually research it right that if we
know think hard about what we want and
we we work hard at you know getting our
own act together first of all and then
also making sure that this
stays and is beneficial you know we have
a good chance to succeed now there will
be a lot of challenges in between you
know from very near-term
issues like Lukas was mentioning for
example autonomous weapons
you know weaponizing our our AI and
giving it the right to harm and kill
humans to other issues regarding income
inequality
you know enhanced by by technological
development and so on to down the road
you know how do we how do we make sure
that autonomous AI systems actually
adopt our goals but I do feel that it is
important to to try and it's important
to work at it and that's what I'm trying
to do and that's what I hope others will
join us in doing alright well thank you
both again for joining us today thanks
for having us thanks for having us this
is wonderful if you're interested in
learning more about the value of lineman
landscape that Lucas was talking about
please visit future of life org slash
value alignment map will also link to
this in the transcript for this podcast
and if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe give it a like and share it on
social media we'll be back again next
month with another conversation among
experts